I can handle like the brain I can handle
like the organs I don't care but the
nose hairs yes
eyelashes that would really yeah hi I'm
Stephanie oh hi I'm Stephanie hi I'm
David I'm Caleb
I'm Lily I'm we're medical students and
we're gonna play a game of never have I
ever
okay let's do it
never have I ever gone a really bad
grade on something in med school but
medical school is pass/fail it is an ass
fail and that is the beauty of it
mine was an auskey Oh like a clinical
skilled assessment type of thing mm-hmm
I really prepare for mine because we had
like that I've written an exam the day
before or the day after or something for
me is a cardio poem exam and I just
barely passed that course but I passed
it never have I ever pulled an
all-nighter and if you have more than
one in a row no you can't do you can't
do more than one hero I have pulled
honors
oh you have I thought you're like the
type that always sleeps at like 9:00
a.m. a 9:00 p.m.
yes I do the function the next day I
don't believe in all-night run I'll go
to bed at like 10:30 every night Wow how
about I just can't would you rather
suffer like 20% everyday and have that
last a week or like 90% in one day like
I made my choice and I regret every time
but I do it every time I have like a
final I'm just like not sleeping that
night never have I ever gone out
drinking with friends after we all
thought we failed an important exam
[Music]
yes you know it's either to celebrate or
to cope yeah every year there's them
there's a Vegas trip that happens after
the first things and then you all get
your grades when you're in Vegas that's
this the perfect time there's still most
people are happy but yes some work or
even if it's not after a final unit so
random weekend never have I ever messed
up when learning or trying to do
something taking quite yeah yeah and
that's what learning is about first we
were practicing intubation which is
basically you know putting tube in
someone's mouth so they can breathe if
they can't breathe on their own and was
mannequins obviously but the very first
thing the doctor said was don't go like
this or else you're gonna break their
teeth and I immediately and some of the
really embarrassing ones are when you're
in the hospital and you're working with
actual doctors you don't know anything
when you're going in as a new medical
student the doctor that I was with
showed me a scan of like a patient it
was pretty severe and I I didn't know at
the time and all I said was just like is
is this
and everyone in the room laughed at me
and I was just like whoa my was actually
taking a light so it's pretty relevant
question yeah never have I ever fallen
asleep in class dude the sleep that you
get in class is the best sleep because
it's like the guilty sleep the good part
about medical school now is that there's
a lot of classes that are podcasted so
now you can fall asleep at home while
watching the video
a 64 student film no yeah yeah that's
true I started just not going to class
I'm just watching at home and sometimes
when you have trouble sleeping you can
put like a podcast on and it's just it's
like white noise that helps you fall
asleep never have I ever thought about
dropping out of med school all right I
guess we we need to do a between
seriously dropping out or joking about
here
yeah easy one easy easiest question in
the dark hours but totally a coping
mechanism yeah it's like that sucked
maybe you should drop out like every
time we have a final I'm like aha yes
studying so much will work
sometimes when I'm just like studying
like late into the night I just think
like I couldn't be like going into
finance making all this you could have a
job yeah I could have a real job be a
real adult but now I'm just studying 15
hours a day in my room shut up like I
haven't seen they're like light of the
day it's just like how much do you
really need to know about the human body
apparently a lot never have I ever felt
squeamish when working with corpses yes
yeah so our first time in anatomy lab we
worked with cadavers and it was like my
first time seeing them so we have a half
of a head so just a head cut in half
and you can still see his nose hairs oh
my god and the note like I can handle
like the brain I can handle like the
organs I don't care but the nose hairs
yeah eyelashes that would really be me
up they basically said you down in a
room
they're like this is what you'll see for
the first time we'll have the faces
cover so that you know it seems a little
bit less you know real issue nothing can
really like prepare you like you've
looked in the textbooks and you've seen
videos and things but it's not the same
as like putting your hands on a body
never have I ever taken a test hungover
I'm doing my all-nighters before so yeah
it's basically how the grand each exam
is worth so much yeah like brisket yeah
I don't you drink alcohol so it would be
impossible for me to come over
never have I ever befriend a professor
yeah some of they're really cool
definitely see our class is super small
we only have like 64 students from so
everyone it'd be weird if you didn't
become front of you know everything yeah
we kind of had a big program that's like
a hundred eighty kids
yeah I don't really know anybody super
well yeah I mean if if they've made the
choice to stay at an academic
institution and be a professor
oftentimes they're really invested in
yeah students I mean we're just students
we're just human beings learning about
other human beings not robust studying
all day God that stops weak to everyone
in medical school has like a different
way of studying and preparing for exams
students will get really stressed out
because they're looking at their friends
they're like oh my gosh like they're
studying it this way and I'm like not
doing this way but you should just do
the way that works for you like pulling
my all-nighters has been working so far
and I don't think I could do it the way
that David does it but David is
successful in the way he does so I think
just do doing trusting in what you know
is good for you you do you yeah you do
[Music]
you
[Music]